yo what how crazy take me to the 82
point game Kobe night you were there 81
or 81. why do I say 80s oh 82 is the
amount of games that get played
um the 81 point game though against the
Raptors where he was just I mean
legendary night man what was that
there's a reason why that coach
it's not coaching anymore who was the
coach
Sam Mitchell oh yeah
he's
his former Timber Wolf back in the day
because the whole time I'm like
yo double team them I want to play
he ain't even changed the defense he
didn't make no adjustment hmm
no zone right we're just gonna sit there
and just let him just talk to your team
it's pretty crazy they had Jalen Rose
forever will be known as I mean an
amazing guy but also the guy who uh was
guarding Kobe most of that game
gave him and we was down 25 in that game
really
you know what's crazy about that game
like I don't see Kobe like hit some like
incredible shots
[ __ ] that you can't imagine and just
that [ __ ] was just like basic Kobe
in that game just will yeah just will
just basic everything was like oh mostly
two foot wasn't no
one leg runners
[Music]
you know a couple of faded ways here and
there but
it was [ __ ] was just basic basketball if
you think about him